- Huh. Adnan Syed from
the "Serial" podcast
was released from jail.
No, that's way too controversial for me.
(bright music)
(phone rings)
- Hello?
- Hey buddy.
- Thanks Devin, and I mean that.
Thank you for having me
be the sacrificial lamb
talking about a wildly
controversial subject
that will almost certainly result
in irrational attacks on me.
I'm doubling my fee, Devin.
Check the invoice.
Adnan Syed, the subject of
the most popular podcast
of all time,
is a free man.
- The stunning reversal in a case
that inspired the "Serial" podcast.
- Officials have dropped all
charges against Adnan Syed
after he spent 23 years in prison.
- [Reporter] Adnan Syed is a free man.
- He walked out of a
Baltimore courthouse today.
- Syed was convicted of
murdering Hae Min Lee in 1999.
This doesn't mean that
he's necessarily innocent,
but the State's Attorney for
Baltimore, Marilyn Mosby,
has just announced that
the state is dropping
all charges against Syed.
- This morning, I instructed my office
to dismiss the criminal
case against Adnan Syed
following the completion of a second round
of touch DNA testing
of items that were never tested before.
- Adnan Syed's case was featured
on the first season of
the podcast "Serial"
which became a true crime sensation.
The podcast was downloaded
over 100 million times.
"Serial" inspired other
podcasts about the case,
several documentaries and
multiple criminal appeals
of Syed's sentence.
This case is also
incredibly controversial,
with some people convinced that
Syed is absolutely innocent.
- I'm innocent, right?
Just like everybody else here.
- And others equally convinced
that he's an unrepentant murderer.
- You guys are pathetic.
You're idolizing a murderer.
- In this episode we're gonna explain
how we got to the point
of Syed walking free after 23 years,
but we are not gonna
try and solve the case.
In other words, we're
doing the characteristic
Legal Eagle thing,
which is annoy everyone
who has a strong opinion.
It's the Legal Eagle brand.
Let's go back to 1999.
In 1999, Hae Min Lee was an honor student
at Woodlawn High School in
Baltimore County, Maryland.
On January 23rd of that year,
when she was 18 years old,
Lee disappeared after leaving school.
There were no witnesses
to her disappearance.
One month later,
her body was found at Leakin Park.
Police determined that she
had been strangled to death
and they eventually arrested Adnan Syed,
Lee's 17-year-old ex-boyfriend,
and charged him with murder.
Syed was also an honor student,
but during the trial
prosecutors made hundreds of references
to Adnan's race and religion,
introducing him to the jury by saying,
"The defendant is of Pakistani
background, he's a Muslim."
Now this was used to explain
the religious and familial tensions
that ultimately led to the breakup
between Lee and Syed
and hence a motive to kill.
But it's not a great look.
- What we've got here is
failure to communicate.
- At the time of trial,
there was no DNA evidence
linking Syed to the murder.
Instead, the state relayed mostly
on the testimony of Jay Wilds,
a friend of Syed's who
was a known drug dealer.
Wilds was a year older than Lee and Syed
and had graduated the year before.
He eventually told the
police that Syed killed Lee.
Wilds allegedly drove to the park
where he watched Syed bury Lee's body.
Here's the basic version of events
the prosecution presented
during the trial.
Around lunchtime on the
day Lee disappeared,
Syed tells Wilds that
he's going to kill Lee.
Wilds then borrows
Syed's car and cellphone
on the condition that Wilds
drops Syed off at school,
which he does.
Wilds then goes to his
friend Jenn Pusateri's house
to hang out.
Syed has a free period
and then gets to his psychology class late
at 1:27 p.m.
That class ends at 2:15
p.m. and, according to Syed,
he goes to track practice later
from 3:30 to 4:30 or 5:00.
Up to this point,
the timelines from Syed and
Wilds are largely similar,
but this is also where they
start to diverge substantially.
And it's this gap in time,
2:15 to 3:30,
that the prosecution focuses on
as the time Syed kills Lee.
According to Wilds,
Syed calls him at some
point in the afternoon
asking Wilds to pick him up later.
Not hearing anything further from Syed,
Wilds eventually leaves Pusateri's house
and drives to his friend Jeff's house.
Jeff wasn't home
and as Wilds is leaving the neighborhood
he gets a call from Syed
asking him to meet at Best Buy.
It's notable that Wilds believed this call
was around 3:30 or so.
Both he and Pusateri
remember Wilds leaving
her house around 3:30.
But the prosecution used a cellphone log
to argue that this phone
call from Syed to Wilds
actually happened at 2:36.
Remember, it is important
to the prosecution
that the murder happened some
time between 2:15 and 3:30.
According to Wilds,
he meets Syed at the Best Buy parking lot
where Syed shows him Lee's body
in the trunk of her own car.
They then ditch Lee's car
at the I-70 Park and Ride
and after buying some marijuana
Wilds drops Syed off at track practice.
Wilds later picks Syed
up from track practice,
Syed retrieves Lee's car,
and ultimately they end up at Leakin Park.
Wilds also testifies
that Syed's phone received two phone calls
while Syed was digging a
hole through Lee's body.
The cellphone records showed
two incoming phone calls
at 7:09 and 7:16
on the day Lee disappeared.
The state then called an
expert from AT&T who testified
that the cell towers where
the calls were received
were connected with cell
sites around Leakin Park.
Wilds' version of events was
somehow backed up by Pusateri.
She confirms that Wilds was at her house
until about 3:30.
She also told police that
when she tried to call Wilds
on Syed's phone that day,
someone else answered and
told her Wilds was busy.
She also said that Wilds later told her
he saw Lee's body at the Best Buy
and that Syed strangled Lee
because Lee broke Syed's heart.
Now something is worth
saying at this point.
This has been a quick summary
and it's not intended to
capture all the issues
identified by people
scrutinizing this case.
Fans of "Serial"
are probably tearing
their hair out right now.
- I'm mad as hell, I'm
not gonna take it anymore!
- For one thing,
the version of events
Wilds testified to at trial
was similar to but not
altogether consistent
with his two interviews with police.
Wilds himself later told an
interviewer from The Intercept
that he was terrified of going to prison
for dealing marijuana
to high school students
and he was also afraid
it would somehow implicate his family
since he based his operations
out of his grandmother's house.
Originally, Pusateri told police
that she didn't know
anything about what happened.
Years later, Pusateri would say
that Wilds was always very convincing.
"He was a good storyteller.
He would make you believe
your shirt was green
if it was blue."
When confronted with the many
versions of Wilds' story,
including one where he sees Lee's body
behind some rowhouses
rather than the Best Buy,
Pusateri concluded that "Jay
obviously picks and chooses
what he tells,
and at this point, it's
created such a mess."
Wilds agreed to cooperate with the police
and was actually charged as
an accessory after the fact.
He told the jury that the
crime was premeditated,
that he heard Syed saying,
"I'm going to kill that bitch,"
just hours before she disappeared.
He also testified that Syed
bragged about the murder
when he showed Wilds the body, saying,
"I killed someone with my bare hands."
Syed's defense was
that he couldn't have
committed the murder.
He went to school, he
went to track practice,
and then he went to pray at his mosque
with his father for Ramadan.
Needless to say,
a jury found him guilty of
murder, robbery, kidnapping,
and false imprisonment,
and he was sentenced to life in prison.
The "Serial" podcast
presented a new witness,
a woman who allegedly
saw Syed at the library
between 2:30 and 2:40
on the day Lee went missing.
Remember, the prosecution argued
that the murder had to have happened
between 2:15 and 3:30 or so.
The witness, Asia McClain,
said that she tried to
testify at Syed's trial
but that his lawyer, Maria Gutierrez,
never contacted her.
It's notable that Gutierrez
was disbarred in 2001
after a series of client complaints.
The podcast also
questioned the reliability
of the cellphone tower records
and revealed that physical
evidence gathered in 1999
was never tested for Mr. Syed's DNA.
In 2015, momentum from "Serial"
helped Syed file an
appeal with new lawyers.
A state court granted Syed a new trial
after his lawyers showed
that Gutierrez had been grossly negligent
for not calling McClain
as an alibi witness.
The lawyers also questioned
the reliability of the
cell tower evidence.
Now Gutierrez had died in 2007,
so she was unable to testify
about why she didn't investigate McClain.
In 2018, the Maryland
Court of Special Appeals
upheld the decision to
grant Syed a new trial
and vacated his conviction
on the grounds that he received
inadequate legal assistance.
- Now didn't I tell you
the next time you appear in my courtroom
that you dress appropriately?
- You was serious about that?
- The state then appealed
to Marylan's highest court,
the Court of Appeals.
Let's take a step back.
What did Adnan Syed have to
prove to get a new trial?
Syed's legal team raised a claim called
ineffective assistance of counsel
in violation of the Sixth Amendment
of the United States Constitution.
Syed's defense team presented
one issue on appeal,
that he was denied effective
assistance of counsel
because Gutierrez failed to even interview
the alibi witness.
An alibi witness is a defendant's claim
that he or she was at another place
at the time where the
alleged crime was committed.
In Strickland v. Washington,
the US Supreme Court
outlined a two-pronged test
for determining whether
a criminal defendant
has received ineffective
assistance of counsel.
The defendant must first prove
that the trial counsel's
performance was deficient.
If the lawyer's performance was deficient,
then the defendant has to prove
that he suffered actual prejudice
by trial counsel's deficiency.
In other words, the
defendant has to demonstrate
that if not for his
counsel's bad performance,
there was a substantial probability
that the jury would not have
convicted the defendant.
The Maryland Court of
Appeals ruled against Syed
in a four-to-three decision
that overturned the lower court ruling.
The Court of Appeals first held
that under the deficient-performance prong
of Strickland v. Washington,
at a minimum,
Syed's trial counsel had a duty
to contact the potential alibi witness
to investigate or explore
that person's background
as a potential as an alibi witness.
The American Bar Association's
standard for defense counsel
required them to conduct
a prompt investigation
of the circumstances of the case
and explore all avenues leading to facts
relevant to the merits of the case
and the penalty in the
event of conviction.
The investigation should include
efforts to secure information
in the possession of the prosecution
and law enforcement authorities.
Gutierrez's failure to
contact an alibi witness
constituted deficient performance
under the first prong
of the Strickland test.
The second prong of the Strickland test
asks whether trial counsel's
deficient performance
resulted in prejudice.
To show prejudice,
a defendant has to show
that there is a reasonable probability
that but for a counsel's
unprofessional errors,
the result of the proceeding
would have been different.
Under this standard,
a defendant must demonstrate either, one,
a reasonable probability
that but for counsel's
unprofessional errors
the result of the proceeding
would have been different,
or two, that the result of the proceeding
was fundamentally unfair or unreliable.
The key question in this analysis
is what constitutes
reasonable probability.
The Supreme Court described it as
"a probability sufficient
to undermine confidence
in the outcome."
Maryland courts interpret
reasonable probability to mean
that "there was a substantial
or significant possibility
that the verdict of the trier of fact
would have been affected."
A court does not presume
that the outcome of a trial
would have been different
just because the lawyer's
performance was deficient,
and that is what doomed Syed's appeal.
The court said that even
if McClain's statements
about seeing Syed in the library was true,
her alibi does little more
that call into question
the time that the state
claimed Miss Lee was killed
and does nothing to rebut the evidence
establishing Mr. Syed's
motive and opportunity
to kill Miss Lee.
Thus, the jury could have disbelieved
that Mr. Syed killed Miss Lee by 2:36 p.m.
as the state's timeline suggested,
yet still believed that Mr. Syed
had the opportunity to kill Miss Lee
after 2:40 p.m.
Miss McClain's testimony
according to her affidavit
failed to account for
Mr. Syed's whereabouts
after 2:40 p.m.
on January 13th, 1999.
Likewise, Mr. Syed's
statements to the police
failed to account for his whereabouts
after 2:15 p.m. when school let out.
Therefore, even if the alibi testimony
had been admitted into evidence,
it could not have affected
the outcome of the case
because that evidence did not negate
Mr. Syed's criminal agency.
So although the court agreed
that Gutierrez's
representation was deficient
because she had failed to
investigate an alibi witness,
the majority concluded that
Syed was not prejudiced
by Gutierrez's mistakes.
The court found that the
jury would have convicted him
based on Wilds' testimony
and the cell tower records.
As a result, Syed did not get a new trial.
But that's not the end of the story.
Syed's claims were given new life in 2020
after a new Maryland law gave
prosecutors the discretion
to modify the sentences of offenders
who were under 18 at
the time of their crimes
if they had served at
least 20 years in prison.
In 2021, Baltimore prosecutors
conducted an investigation
into the circumstances
of Syed's conviction
with the help of Syed's lawyers.
In March of 2022,
Baltimore prosecutors
agreed to new DNA testing,
saying that it was merited
because of advances
in genetic science.
The prosecutor agreed
to the defense's request
for touch DNA testing,
which was not available at
the time of Syed's trial.
In September, prosecutors filed a motion
to vacate Syed's conviction.
Mosby accused the State
Attorney General's Office
of Brady violations.
Now the Brady Rule requires prosecutors
to disclose materially
exculpatory evidence
in the government's possession
to the defense.
Basically, this means that the prosecution
has to tell the defendant
about any evidence
that would potentially
negate a defendant's guilt,
that would reduce a
defendant's potential sentence,
or evidence going to the
credibility of the witness.
The prosecutors' motion
said that prosecutors
on the case decades ago
knew that there was another suspect
who threatened to kill Lee
and neglected to disclose that information
to defense attorneys.
Mosby asked that Syed be
granted a new trial at a minimum
and released on his own
personal recognizance.
A local judge agreed and Syed was freed.
Mosby's office then had 30
days to complete its review.
Maryland Attorney General Brian Frosh
released a statement
disputing Mosby's allegations.
"Among the other serious problems
with the motion to vacate,
the allegations related to
Brady violations are incorrect.
Neither State's Attorney Mosby
nor anyone from her office
bothered to consult
with either the Assistant State's Attorney
who prosecuted the case
or with anyone in my office
regarding those alleged violations.
The file in this case was made available
on several occasions to the defense."
The friction between Mosby and Frosh
brings up another point.
Why would Mosby exonerate Syed now?
The Maryland Supreme
Court denied Syed's appeal
and the US Supreme Court
refused to hear the case.
That would have finalized his conviction.
(gavel thudding)
Activists on both sides of the Syed case
think that the decision
was politically motivated.
Here's DeRay Mckesson who
championed Syed's innocence
pointing out that Mosby
has some credibility issues
of her own.
"See, here's the thing.
Mosby had the new DNA evidence
a la Adnan for a while now.
She didn't just get it yesterday.
Why was the announcement yesterday?
She waited to announce
to drown out coverage
of her own indictment."
And here's a blog post from
The Manhattan Institute
which argues against the
reforms Mosby tried to enact
and blames her for the city's
skyrocketing murder rate.
"With the city reeling and
her reputation in tatters,
the safest exit strategy for Mosby
would have been to wind
down her role quietly,
hoping that nobody noticed
as she skulked off to
face her federal charges.
Instead, Mosby is reinforcing
her de-prosecution credentials,
executing on a plan to free Adnan Syed,
convicted of killing a teenage girl."
Their point? Well, Marilyn Mosby
was a lame duck.
- You're despicable.
- She was one of the first prosecutors
elected on a platform of decarceration.
And that was in 2014.
In 2022, Baltimoreans
did not reelect Mosby.
The Federal Government indicted Mosby
on two counts of perjury
and two counts of making false statements
on a loan application.
The perjury counts involve Mosby
allegedly falsely claiming
a Covid-19 hardship
on applications to withdraw $90,000
from her retirement account.
The tax-free withdrawal option
was one of the benefits of the CARES Act.
Now the prosecutors'
investigation is complete.
Mosby looked at three main issues.
DNA, alternate suspects,
and cellphone evidence.
Mosby said her office received DNA testing
on Lee's skirt, nylons, jacket, and shoes.
- Those items include skirt, pantyhose,
shoes and jacket
of Miss Hae Min Lee.
- [Devin] Forensic
scientists could not recover
any DNA from the first three,
but they did find a DNA mixture
of multiple contributors
on Lee's shoes.
Mosby said, "Most compellingly,
Adnan Syed's DNA was excluded."
- And most compellingly,
Adnan Syed, his DNA was excluded.
- Trace level male DNA
was detected on Lee's
right fingernail swabs,
the right fingernail clipper swabs,
and the victim's shirt swabs.
The swabs from the right
fingernail and shirt
were then analyzed,
but no useful typing results were obtained
from this analysis.
Another shirt swab
and the right hand fingernail
clippings were not analyzed
because it was determined
that the amount of male DNA
was so minimal
it would not likely produce any results.
With respect to Brady material
on alternate suspects,
the Prosecutor's Office said they found
"a separate document from
the original trial file
in which a different
person relaid information
that can be viewed as a
motive for the same suspect
to harm the victim.
This information about the
threat and motives to harm
could have provided a
basis for the defense
and was not disclosed to the trial
nor the post-conviction defense counsel."
Mosby said that new
information also revealed
that one of the suspects
was convicted of attacking
a woman in her vehicle
and that one of the suspects was convicted
of engaging in serial
rape and sexual assault.
The investigators found out
that Lee's car was located
right behind the house
of one of this suspect's family members.
Some of this information was
available at the time of trial,
some of the events
occurred after the trial,
according to the news release.
As for the cellphone tower data,
the prosecutors found that
"based on the cellular technology
at the time of the incident in this case,
it was possible that an incoming call
could be recorded at the
last registered tower sector
and not the current one
when the signal was sent
across multiple towers
within an area."
The investigative team
said that two other experts
verified this conclusion.
Mosby said that the investigation
into Lee's murder continues,
but she declined to offer any details.
Presumably, the investigators will look
at the possible involvement
of two alternative
suspects other than Syed.
We don't know if the suspects
are involved individually
or involved together.
According to the trial file,
one of these suspects said,
"He would make her disappear,
he would kill her,"
referring to Miss Lee.
Mosby characterized Syed's conviction
as a miscarriage of justice.
- As the administrator of
the criminal justice system,
it's my duty to ensure
that justice is not delayed,
justice is never denied,
but justice be done.
- Lee's family does not
agree that justice was done.
They've expressed concerns
about why the Baltimore
County Prosecutor's Office
abruptly exonerated Syed
after insisting on his guilt for decades.
- They're very said.
I think they feel very hopeless
about any future justice being brought.
- The family also felt excluded
from the prosecutors' decision-making,
stating that they were not informed
about the progress of the investigation.
On September 29th,
Lee's family filed a motion
opposing Syed's release,
asking a court to halt
the legal proceedings
to address alleged violations
of a state victim's rights law.
Lee's family says that
prosecutors didn't let them know
that they intended to
vacate Syed's sentence.
The motion says
that two days after prosecutors
filed the motion to vacate
there was a meeting between prosecutors
and Syed's attorneys.
The family says they were not
notified of the proceeding
and were later informed an
in-person hearing was scheduled
for the next business day,
leaving them with no opportunity
to attend or be heard.
Young Lee, who is Hae's brother,
filed a motion on the same
day as the September hearing,
stating he didn't have
enough notice to attend.
The court went into recess
for about 30 minutes
while a call was hastily arranged
for Young Lee to express his confusion.
The court hasn't ruled
on the family's motion,
but it's unlikely to change the outcome.
Lee's family put out a statement, saying,
"All this family ever wanted
was answers and a voice.
Today's actions robbed them of both."
And now let me burst
the true crime bubble.
Lee's family believes in Syed's guilt
and they have good reasons to.
There is a glaring hole
in the defense argument
that McClain provided Syed
with a rock-solid alibi.
In his accounts of where he went
on the day Lee was killed,
Syed never said that he was at
the Woodlawn Public Library.
McClain's testimony conflicted
with Syed's accounts
of his whereabouts that day,
which of course made Gutierrez's
client look untruthful.
Gutierrez got into trouble
with the bar on other matters,
but that doesn't mean that she was wrong
not to reach out to McClain.
There's another problem
with the Adnan was at the library alibi.
It doesn't account for his whereabouts
after about 2:40 p.m.
The state always asserted
that Lee was killed
between 2:15 p.m. and 2:45 p.m.,
but they don't know for sure.
Syed still had time to leave
the library, strangle Lee,
get Wilds' help with the body,
and then head back to track
practice by early evening.
There's yet another angle
to the McClain story.
How do we know she's telling the truth?
The Attorney General's Office
said that two of McClain's classmates
contacted them with allegations
that she made the story up.
The witnesses, who are sisters,
remember talking with McClain about it
in their co-op class,
and I quote,
"Both my sister and I, more so my sister,
argued with Asia about how
serious this situation was.
She just said that it
wouldn't hurt anything,
that if he was truly guilty,
then he would be convicted.
I'm not sure what can
come of this information,
but I felt I had to let someone know."
Lots of people will say
that these two classmates
who remain anonymous
must be the liars.
But that's the problem.
People tend to draw inferences
about who's telling the truth
based on which side they're rooting for.
McClain apparently wasn't so sure
that her alibi meant Syed was innocent.
It seems even McClain knew
that if she saw Syed in the library,
it did not mean he wouldn't
have had time to kill Lee.
She wrote to him when he
first went to prison, saying,
"If you are innocent, I
will do my best to help you.
But if you're not, only God can help you."
McClain later published a book called
"Confessions of a Serial Alibi."
The Attorney General's Office pushed back
against Mosby's claim
that the McClain information
was withheld from the defense.
"Among the other serious problems
with the motion to vacate,
the allegations related to
Brady violations are incorrect."
The office said in a news
release issued after the hearing,
"Neither State's Attorney Mosby
nor anyone else from her office
bothered to consult
with either the Assistant State's Attorney
who prosecuted the case
or with anyone in my office
regarding these alleged violations.
The file in this case
was made available on several occasions
to the defense."
Moreover, it's worth pointing out
that the inconsistencies
in Wilds' accounts
of what happened that day
were actually addressed head on
by the prosecution during trial.
And then there's the
new touch DNA evidence.
It revealed that there were
multiple DNA contributors
on Lee's shoe,
but none of them Syed.
So what does that mean?
Well, honestly, not a lot.
It could mean Syed never touched the shoe,
or it could mean Syed did touch the shoe
but not enough or in the right way
to transfer his DNA onto it.
By itself, it really doesn't mean much.
So although Adnan Syed has been exonerated
by the State of Maryland,
the question remains.
Who killed Hae Min Lee
back in January of 1999?
Was it one suspect
or two people working in concert?
Did investigators know their names
during Syed's trial in 2000?
Sources say that Baltimore
County prosecutors
are mostly considering old suspects.
Of course, there was presumably a reason
that these suspects weren't
pursued in the original case.
What were those reasons?
And what did the Maryland
Attorney General's Office
know about them?
And perhaps, most importantly,
is Mosby able to test those suspects' DNA?
Only time will tell,
but Syed will be spending
that time a free man.
- Oh, well, yeah,
now that Adnan is out of jail
he'll probably want a
delicious home-cooked meal
delivered straight to his door,
which he can get with
today's sponsor HelloFresh.
HelloFresh is a great way
to eat delicious fresh food
while still being healthy.
In fact, HelloFresh has a whole variety
of calorie-smart, carb-smart,
pescatarian and veggie options
so you can customize it how you like too.
HelloFresh delivers fresh quality produce
from the farms to your
door in less than a week,
so you can enjoy seasonal favorites
like cowboy turkey and black bean chili,
mushroom ravioli with kale and walnuts,
or sweetcorn and green pepper chowder.
Now I'm a do-it-yourself person
and I have to say I was initially
pretty skeptical about HelloFresh.
I'm a pretty good cook
so I didn't think that I needed the help,
but I actually loved it.
Even for an experienced cook,
HelloFresh delivers new
ingredients and recipes
that I'd never try on my own.
They usually keep
everyone's favorite meals
and then rotate new ones in all the time.
In fact, I usually increase
the size of my HelloFresh servings
so I can enjoy leftovers for lunches.
And of course everything was
delivered straight to my door
so I didn't have to do any shopping.
The produce actually gets to you faster
than at a grocery store,
so it arrives at peak
freshness and flavor,
and it's also super easy to save time.
HelloFresh cuts out the
meal planning and prep
so the recipes only take
20 to 30 minutes to cook,
literally less time to cook
than it would normally take me
to do the shopping.
And it's also incredibly sustainable.
Since the ingredients are pre-portioned,
there's less prep and less wasted food.
The packaging is almost
entirely made from recyclable
or already recycled content,
and HelloFresh's carbon footprint
is actually 25% lower
than that of meals made
from store-bought groceries.
And of course it's 72% cheaper
than dining at a restaurant.
So if you'd like to try HelloFresh,
go to hellofresh.com and
use the code LegalEagle60
for 60% off plus free shipping.
Yes, you can actually get
60% off plus free shipping
by clicking on the link
that's on screen right now
or down in the description.
So go to hellofresh.com and
use the code LegalEagle60
or just click on the link below.
Plus, clicking that link
really helps out this channel.
And after that, click on
this playlist over here
for more Legal Eagle,
or I'll see you in court.